es ist das tragische ende einer
gartenparty am samstagabend ist
gemeinderat nico k von der cdu auf einer
feier in höhnstedt in sachsen anhalt als
plötzlich ein gewitter aufzieht verlässt
der 44-jährige den garten um pinkeln zu
gehen
dabei steht er unter einer stromleitung
wird vom blitz getroffen und ist sofort
tot
thilo scholtyseck ist in höhnstedt thilo
was kannst du uns zu nico k sagen dem
cdu politiker die zu seinem tod geführt
haben
kuka war mit einigen freunden ist eine
gelaufen grundstück im wald das ist also
keine keine gartenparzelle sondern
wirklich eine zweite fläche sie hat nur
kleinen grillplatz das war eine gruppe
von sechs bis acht leuten und man hat
fröhlich ausgelassen gefeiert man das
begriffen hat was getrunken und in der
stunde zwischen 21 uhr bis 22.30 war das
unwetter in diesen bereichen dazu hat
besonders starkes gab es starkregen bis
zu 40 litern pro quadratmeter blitze und
genau in so einem augenblick als
pokal-aus grad und mal geklingelt hat
einen baum
man kann es nicht klar erkennen das ist
wirklich ein holzmast strommast ist aus
holz erst in dem augenblick als er seine
notdurft verrichtet der schlug der blitz
ein
die anderen haben natürlich sofort
versucht hilfe zu holen
wie gesagt alles ist verletzt worden
aber letztlich konnten die retter und
die feuerwehrleute die am ort eintreffen
nur noch den tod des opfers feststellen
wie der ganze ort ist natürlich mächtig
schockiert dass wir heute mit leuten
gesprochen haben den niko kapanen
überaus beliebter nachbarn und mitbürger
meine